[موسيقى]
الكثيرون يعرفون انسبورك باستراليا كوجهه
للتزلج ولكن ما لا يعلمه البعض هو انها
تضم مركزا طموحا للابحاث
لطالما كان العالم جريند جرومر مفتونا
بالفضاء الخارجي بدا الامر عندما كان عم
حوالي 16 عاما وكنت انظر من خلال التلسكوب
وادركت ان كل ما هو مثير للاهتمام ليس على
الارض وانما في
الفضاء تدرب جرينارد ليكون عالما
بالفيزياء والفلك ولكنه اصبح الان عالما
بالبيولوجيا الفلكيه ليبحث عن علامات وجود
الحياه في الفضاء فلماذا اختار
المريخ قد يكون المكان الوحيد الذي يوفر
لنا ما نحتاجه لمعرفه ما اذا وجدت حياه
غير الارض امضى هذا العالم ست سنوات وهو
يصنع العده المثاليه للذهاب الى
المريخ هذه اودا اكس وهي بدله للفضاء
قادره على التكيف مع كل العوائق التي قد
تواجهها على سطح
المريخ استطيع الاكل والشرب داخل هذه
البدله فهي تعمل على تكنولوجيا حديثه
للغايه واجهزه للاستشعار ولكنها لا تخلو
من بعض الاساسيات التي ليست لها دخل
بالتكنولوجيا فمثلا وضعت هذه القطعه
لتساعد في حك الوجه او ازاله
العرق كيف تختلف هذه البدله الفضائيه عن
الباقي هذه ابرع بدله تم صنعها والفرق هو
ان بدلنا تعتبر محورا مركزيا لمجموعه من
المعدات الروبوتيه ومن المعروف ان جو
المريخ لا يلائم فهو مكان بارد جدا وتميزه
عواصف ترابيه تم اختبار البدله في صحار
المغرب وفي كهوف جليديه تحت الارض بالنمس
وهذه اماكن تشبه سطح
المريخ ولكن جرينارد جرومر ليس وحده فهناك
العديد من العلماء يعملون على تصميم بدلات
تتوافق مع سطح المريخ مثل ناسا ومجموعه
ابحاث في يوتا
h